This is where the knowledge
representation helps a lot.
The semantic network knowledge
representation provides a level of
abstraction at which the problem
gets represented and analyzed.
So, although this particular diamond
y could have been displaced here or
a little bit further, it could have been
of this size, maybe a little smaller,
a little bit larger.
The semantic network really
doesn't care about it.
With the level of extraction which
a semantic network is dealing,
y gets expanded, and
that is all that matters.
An important point to note here is
that any knowledge representation
picks a level of extraction at
which it represents the world.
There's a lot of power in
it because that knowledge
representation ignores things that
are at a low level of detail.
And therefore the problem-solving
method doesn't have to worry
about those things.
So it is not the knowledge
representation alone
that solves the problem, or the problem
solving method that solves the problem.
It is the knowledge representation and
the problem solving method
coupled together that solve the problem,
that provide the reasoning.